[Musique]
ça va tous encore en forme
ah oui je suis bien beau si ça va vous
êtes en forme chez vous tout va bien pas
de problème ça l'essentiel a alors là il
a bien travaillé j'en suis sûr toukan
quand même à préparer une expérience
extraordinaire
aïe moi j'ai pas bien mais alors je veux
bien te l'expliquer on veut bien qu'on
la fasse mais alors à une seule
condition abondé condition maintenant
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça pour toi
fabrice oui j'aimerais qu'ils me fassent
une grimace non ce jour furent une
grimace devant tout le monde
vallauris fait une grimace en nouveaux
baux furent une grimace nous ça fait
rire toute la forêt l'autre jour oui
d'accord mais dans la forêt je te faire
une grimace mais ici les sa non pas
maintenant c'est terminé alors
l'émission bonsoir mesdames bon nombre
d'accord alors si c'est comme ça que tu
le prends je vais faire une grimace
avait fait le dromadaire le draw matin
oui vraiment le trouver l'air j'aurais
tout fait le dromadaire
je vais faire le dromadaire attention
asie et au bon sens autant madère il a
fait c'est pourtant maintenant tu es
content je me suis ridiculiser devant
tout le monde trouve ça rigolo on peut y
aller oui d'accord tu sais moi a fait
faire n'importe quoi sans fin ni content
mais les belles collant parfaitement car
n'importe quoi alors oui j'ai une faim
qu'est-ce que j'en fais bon alors tu
l'introduit délicatement dans le grand
bocal qui est déjà rempli d'eau ah bon
alors je mets la bouteille le petit
flacon rempli de vin que nous avons
attaché avec un fil dans le bade
jusqu'au fond bah oui mais alors il faut
je trempe ma maman alors mais c'est pas
ça va pas abîmer record mais dit non tu
vas tu laisses tomber votre tombe et là
et là qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant
tu vas le vin va sortir de la bouteille
arrêts et puis il y aura plus que de
l'eau à la place du vin
ça change tout seul alors sa tante lui
pas si je me suis un peu sur tes plus a
dit non tu fous là donc ça mord stop à
temps ne bouge pas trop parce que tu va
renverser tout alors là le vin sort tout
seul à jouer tu vois on regarde c'est
très joli même avoir ce van imschoot on
dire une semaine oui on c'est étonnant
ça et ça va se vider complètement oui
aux aidants une heure ce sera quelqu'un
on va pas vraiment rester une heure pour
le fait un peu ça va demander quoi trois
minutes pendant deux ans et j'aimerais
c'est inouï sa victime me refaire une
grimace cela non non non coupant
exagérer non plus je pense faire des
grimaces comme ça et moyens d'un
tortueux pas non je crois dans un
tortueux non non non non je sois pris la
carapace aujourd'hui c'est du vin lourd
tu vois si ça c'est pas c'est pas vu
petit vent léger
nous amis là bas et coup tu sais ce
qu'on va faire non tu vas sortir pendant
ce temps là où il est oui mais ça
m'intéresse c'est dommage c'est
fascinant c'est une foire dieu en
adressant les açores les cas tu
reviendras et ben la bouteille sera vie
à bon d'accord ben alors je veux tu être
aimé ouais bon à tout à l'heure vous
venez m'aider à me gérer une nouvelle
vie faire mais on va lui faire
maintenant le jeu du point commun ce cas
vous savez la belle belle oui oui oui ça
y est moi j'ai préparé tout tu veux
commencer où je commence à lasser ceux
qui comme moi rémois mais oui c'est toi
laurent feutry pas à brive
voilà j'arrive j'avais déjà fait des tas
d'autres animaux apprenez le ferais là
donc ça marche la bouteille vous croyez
que ça va aller vers la victoire là
c'était comment cette histoire
bon alors là c'est alors si le point
comme la musique on nous allons te
raconter une petite histoire hein et
puis différent chaque a une version
différente les malgré tout ya un point
commun entre nous je sais j'ai un peu
l'impression d'être devant un tribunal
là vous êtes tous installés comme ça moi
je suis assis plus bas que vous tuez la
presse oxygène ne trouve pas ça va mal
aller pour moi
très gentiment bon toute façon mes amis
jouent avec nous et eux aussi doivent
trouver la solution
on voir si ensemble nous parvenons à
faire des mirages je vous écoute bien
alors cette fois-ci moi je suis un marin
gilles oui je suis là j'ai fait des
dizaines de fois le tour du monde en
moins oui mais maintenant c'est fini
tout ça je me repose maintenant je me
promène sur le pont avec ma casquette un
petit peu de travers la la pipe au bec
montpellier danse qui commence à
grisonner alors je vais de temps en
temps au bout de l'acheter je me balance
ans de droite et de gauche de gauche et
de droite tu vois alors je regarde les
bateaux qui retrouve port et alors là à
la syrie un jour quand elle est bel et
bien voilà c'est tout alors terrain
marin quoi alors à voix oui abel belle
attention moi me chivot je suis un
volcan pour l'instant je les enviais
tranquille vous me prenez pour une
petite montagne qu'on a envie d'escaladé
mais faites attention je sens en moi
quelque chose qui me ronge et qui
pourrait bien exploser d'une seconde à
l'autre
vous savez que dans ses colonnes un jeu
de gagne pain
je recouvre tout je le débat a su le
villes entières
souvenez-vous de pompéi rôle est
terrible ça m'a pas l'air commode c'est
à moi un pouce moussu alors et moi
pendant ce temps là qu'est ce que je
fais mais je vous le demande
eh bien ça va peut-être vous étonner
mais je travaille
oui et je travaille dur car je suis une
usine une très grande usine avec
beaucoup de bâtiments beaucoup de
machines beaucoup de cheminées et
beaucoup d'ouvriers alors je je fabrique
que tout ce que vous voulez les
automobiles des grues des locomotives
il fait toujours très très chaud chez
moi très chaud et même en hiver
jeune je crache le feu
oh et et voilà oui un début au début
j'étais bien embarrassée parce que entre
le marin et le volcan n'est pas très
bien le rapport alors pouces moussu m'a
aidé parce que ils viennent nous parler
du sinn
bon alors entre l'usiné elle vole quand
on voit à peu près ce qu'il peut y avoir
de commun mais lors le marin et pourtant
il me semble que tu m'as dit qui est tu
avais une pipe tout cas encore un oui ça
une importance
tu ne peux pas me le cacher je ne peux
pas bon alors je pense que cette fois ci
je sais de quoi il s'agit je suppose que
vous également
vous avez découvert j'espère je me
trompe pas que un volcan ça fume une
usine ça fume et un vieux loup de mer
avec une pipe sa famille alors un qui
est le plus fort
rv et qui sait le champion hier fabrice
bien bon et maintenant nous allons quand
même te poser un premier à qu'est ce que
tu veux mourir bête
oui je m'en vais parce que tu sais bien
que j'ai pris maritime était donc oui on
fait signer ça c'est très bon pour sa
personne oui ça moi c'est mon jeu alors
alors fabrice cette semaine c'est un mot
de cette lettre 1 comme d'habitude le
petit jeu tu te souviens oui je me
sentais sereine quand je me lève oui
alors tu te lèves qu'il faut attendre
journée de travail ici ah ben je me lève
les tripes ça je veux tu que je
t'accompagne non non j'aime le futur est
à ta place
oui et que tu sois attentif aux
questions que je vais poser d'accord
d'accord alors alors c'est un mot de
cette lettre cette laiterie tu bien sûr
j'en suis sûr mauricette on commence pas
par la dernière lettre de l'alphabet un
z d'un z
il a dit non il n'y a pas beaucoup de
mots qui commence par z arriver là après
après tu fais cinq petits points ou cinq
petites règles qui remplace les lettres
manquantes sacrement 4,5
là est la dernière lettre c'est un ace
voilà le sls vent n'ont pas dit non je
connais pas beaucoup de mots qui
commence par un z et qui se termine par
un ace mais il est bien armé racj est ce
que c'est alors la question habituelle
pour commencer et est ce que c'est un
animal
ah non non non c'est pas un animal non
là ça commence bien
est ce que quand est-ce que c'est une
plante
ah oui oui ça serait plutôt une plante
un hallali fleurs annoncé pas une fleur
c'est une plante baisse plombée par un z
ah ouais dommage que vous puissiez pas
en souffrir parce que les planches un
autre est foutue veux tu que je te donne
là la troisième lettre au oui
la troisième oui alors la 3e net c'est
un r r oui alors avec ça tu dois trouver
ça devient facile
m qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être que ça
c'est une plante verte
bah oui oui selon sa mère près des mares
prédéry frais var sur surtout de talent
a toujours beaucoup organe a beaucoup
c'est toujours oui oui oui oui on lui
dit que c'est toujours au pluriel ce we
à douala sont toujours au pluriel
est-ce que c'est est ce que ce sont des
plantes qu'on cultive dans son jardin
pardon non c'est plutôt sauvage
on essaie plutôt de s'en débarrasseront
oui oh oh oh oui mais c'est mais
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien m
et c'est pas d'une autre couleur que le
vert à sévère c'est pervers sévère
verrons bien mais qu'est ce que ça peut
être que ça par un z et r17 ça fait mal
on va l'aja veut ça ça pique ça pis la
wii speak for men ça pique nique
soit je viens de trouver mais alors là
rires ah ça pique abacha rebiquent un
apu que ce serait pas des orties basse
et les oranges un cd sorti at war il est
désormais sorti avec un z avec la scène
c'est dit mais vraiment c'est un monde à
voir ça les orties ça s'écrit orties
pouces moussu est vraiment sorti ont été
sortis les orties c'est la liaison sais
c'est la liaison avec les orties mais si
ça s'écrit au rti1 e et s à vous voilà
au lycée horticole et non j'en ris parce
qu'on fait la liaison bonbons et vous
vous êtes mis à deux pour faire ça tu
veux c'est monstrueux
vous êtes de moins en moins bons en
orthographe est terrible heureusement
que j'ai je suis comme vous je finis par
penser comme une room
non vous aviez trouvé ça incroyable
écoute moi j'ai souvent habité dans des
endroits où il y avait beaucoup d heures
de sortie doit faire un don par deux
panneaux de de beaucoup de d'ortie les
gens attendu des enfants qui criaient
parce qu'ils étaient venus jouer là où
il ya des des sorties là comme tu dirais
et il avait des piqûres plein les gens
me grattait et grattait alors moi j'ai
envie de leur dire mais mais ne criez
pas rentrer chez vous et frottez vous
avec du vinaigre vous verrez ça en
quelques minutes vous ne sentirez plus
rien à mes enfants
bah ils veulent pas m'écouter bien sûr
veulent pas m'écouter sous prétexte que
je ne suis qu'une petite motte de terre
nous sommes en suivant je me rends bien
compte mais je suis sûr tout le monde va
écouter pouces mousseron du vinaigre
puis sont les piqûres d'orties
exactement c'est d'accord on y fait
attention avec du vinaigre d'accord nous
avons noté pas de problème à touques
encore c'est un grand moment maintenant
à nous allons avoir belle belle kim a
chanté son nom structure oui je te la
présente on si tu veux aller enfin comme
une star alors vous mesdames messieurs
boscher fabrice oui j'ai l'honneur de
vous présenter belle baie en vo
[Musique]
mais
annie un achat groupé pour moi aussi
on va ainsi de l'unemig
montez montez quant aux écrans nous
sommes passés par moscou à delhi
faire entendre les chants du foot
[Musique]
mais au fait
ge fabuleux op tout notre
[Musique]
et
bravo ah oui ça va bien je me sens tout
juste d'avion quelle joie de vous revoir
vous avez remarqué comme je prends vite
les axes souffre et les sépare est
prudent mais esprit j'ai préservé une
surprise
j'ai quelque part dans mes bagages des
cadeaux pour les émissions
qu'importe je les retrouverai plus tard
vous serez content moi je suis déjà dit
nous que ces bagues et des bagues de
baguettes de tambour au des baguettes
pour manger ah bon des baguettes
pourvoyons aaron de russie évidemment
j'ai réussi en fait cette question j'ai
fait une brusque ou paris dans des
conditions de confort remarquable
je me sens en pleine forme tout prête à
repartir je me souviens vos baguettes
sont rangés avec le cadeau destiné à ma
tante adèle c'est un très beau saladier
en bois d'olivier je les achetais aux
environs de leningrad dans un village
d'artisans très pittoresque tout autour
ce n'était que des collines couvertes
d'olivier un oeil dans le levier oui
comment propre maman difficile de manger
avec des baguettes aurait ses faveurs au
début que sur vos fans attaché a été
très aimable elle m'a donné une ou deux
leçons ça y est je savais ce que boris
reagan ma maladresse
il me l'a dit mme pech bike entre les
deux pays il faut se soumettre aux
moeurs des habitants c'est mon principe
fin j'ai vu tellement de choses en
russie tu me pose même pas question
fabrice a fait une même ça devrait
atterrir mais si je suis sûr que tu as
vu des choses et le temps d'une ancienne
gare de huy huit jours en asie fille en
allées du caucase en sibérie ennuyeuse
sont au dessus des monts de chasse
quilles afin d'arpenter le plateau de
l'âne à dire je suis revenu à leningrad
on ne connaît pas la russie si l'on n'a
pas visité cette ancienne capitale dont
les palais se mirent sur les hauts de la
neige
mais comme tu sais bien mais moi je
t'écoute répondants disaient les palais
qui se mire dans l'eau de l'année je
suis ensuite retourné une centaine de
kilomètres de moscou dans la datcha de
mes chers amis paul coffey pas d'accord
je vous avais déjà pas un bon psy voyons
je vous avais parlé tous les polluants
fabrice j'aime pas que mon cousin avec
les poyas coffre qu'elles vivent des
messieurs nous avons mené ensemble qui
accueille d'anciens artistes
chaque soir des voisins venus se joindre
à nous celui qui a porté son violon
celui là son sac sur de la musique
jusqu'à l'aube
natacha l'ennemi la danse elle était si
gracieuse avec leurs longs chalets se
ressemblent beaucoup
il pour toutes les deux de grands
peignent des cayes quelques dans leur
chignon noir j'ai rapporté 1 peines
identiques aux leurs quand il faudra que
je pousse à vous le montre un de ces
jours oui ça m'intéresserait ça oui oui
et alors si tous les teams dit non
simplement je suis en train de réfléchir
à ce que tu viens de nous raconter ma
chère elle belle fille est fort
intéressant et ça c'est bien
oui c'est bien typiquement russe ont peu
fait mais oui je crois que j'étudie
c'est ça ben moi je ne dirai rien parce
que je veux pas faire de la peine pour
quoi
qu'est ce que ce qui se dessine moi ce
qui s'en vient enfin les oliviers oui
alors du côté de lénine guinio les
plains les grands peigne en écaille y en
a plein à tunis et dans les cheveux des
russes lundi
oui fabrice grand châle également oui
les baguettes et fabrice les baptêmes
les baguettes pour manger oui le
baguette a dit mme ouellet et l'ailleurs
de dire que je suis monté voir
[Musique]
sa part commencé non sainte hélène c'est
un monde de voir ça va pas recommencer
belle belle si la crise de l'année
barreaux c'est la crise à votre choix
c'est ce programme enfin je suis content
car toi aussi tu as remarqué qu'elle
nous raconter des craques
enfin quoi les baguettes 1 pourquoi
exagéré le monde sait que ça se trouve
en chine depuis tant marqué les oliviers
à leningrad qui a remarqué les châles et
les peignes en écaille dans les cheveux
à l'andorre nommé à mon avis tu veux que
je te dise elle meurt dans vie d'aller
faire des convoyages et comme elle ne
peut pas le faire parce qu'elle n'a pas
le temps sur les ailes les invente
elle est furieuse à chaque fois enfin ce
pas grave tu sais qu'elle oublie
toujours la prochaine fois elle
reviendra et ce sera la même chose nous
racontera un autre voyage aussi
imaginaire didon ça t'intéresse pas
dormir marine enfin rennes elle doit
charbonnel bordeaux rappeuse alors au
tournoi le résultat de temps tu vas voir
ja marois que tout est arrangé là ça a
marché mais oui ça a marché d'un peu de
patience la nasa il faut bien expliquer
alors rappelons ce que nous avons fait
nous avons plongé dans ce bocal qui
était rempli d'eau un petit flacon dans
lequel il y avait du vin et le vin est
sorti tout seul et a été remplacé par de
l'eau bon si vous me demandez quelle est
très exactement l'explication
scientifique de cette affaire-là je
suppose car je ne suis tout de même pas
très calé il doit y avoir une différence
de densité entre les deux liquides et
que le vin est remplacé par l'eau qui
doit être d'une densité plus légère là
je m'avance peut être un peu toi
vraiment je suis pas très fort en
physique je suppose que c'est un système
comme ça vous avez vu comme on l'avait
fait le flacon qui est maintenant rempli
d'eau voilà le flacon qui a été remplie
d'eau tout seul
sa demande est à peu près de 4000 villes
dans oui c'est long
qui est plus lourde ces longues et plus
longs cheveux bruns et oui j'avais
jamais remarqué en la buvant à brice le
vin étant plus léger et monte à bridas
corp willow le remplace oui c'est
curieux comme quand je bois du vin ça ne
fait pas été fait l'a enfin c'est tu
dois avoir raison parce que tu es
beaucoup plus fort en physique comme moi
c'est vrai ça doit être ça la bonne
explication léger comme une plume mais
c'est vrai si vous avez un doute
demandez donc à votre papa ou à votre
moment j'aurais peut-être pu difficultés
que moi vous expliquer le vrai
fonctionnement
mais ils finiront par le trouver soyez
en sûr à très bientôt amusez vous bien
au revoir
[Musique]
à